ich denke die wenigsten von euch wissen
dass ich riesiger Fußballfan bin mein
absoluter lieblingsferein ist bussia
Dortmund aber ich supporte auch den
ersten fC Köln und Arminia Bielefeld
egal ob erste zweite dritte Liga oder
teilweise sogar vierte ich gucke echt
immer Fußball wenn Fußball läuft
deswegen habe ich mir eine Map mit allen
Vereinen aus Europa gebaut und einen
Pfeil auf die Karte geworfen um dann zum
jeweiligen Stadion zu fahren mein erster
Pfeil traf den niederländischen
Erstligisten vitess Arnhem also ging es
mit einem Kollegen direkt 250 km nach
Holland zum Spiel gegen excelsor
Rotterdam fürs Spiel und das Stadion hat
hat sich der Weg leider nicht wirklich
gelohnt das Spiel ist 0 ausgegangen
Stadion war jetzt nicht so
[Gelächter]
besondersit Käse ist wunderbar aber wir
waren auch in der Stadt unterwegs und
die ist echt geil tolle Aussicht von
Motel und viele
studentenbars was meint ihr in welches
Stadion muss ich unbedingt mal rein